les actions unilatérales de la turquie
en méditerranée orientale la politique
agressive de la turquie en libye la
politique de la turquie dans le
haut-karabakh son déferrement de
déstabilisation majeure
mais monsieur le sénateur ces dernières
semaines nous avons franchi dans nos
relations avec la turquie un palier
inadmissible entre pays alliés les
insultes et calomnies la volonté d'un si
une campagne de haine à l'égard de la
france et de l'europe sont de nature
totalement différente ce sont des
menaces
nous attendons donc que le président
turc et son gouvernement mettent un
terme immédiat à ces comportements et
nous ne tolérerons pas non plus que
cette aide cette violence soit exportée
sur le territoire français en étant
relayées par des groupuscules qui ne
doivent pas avoir le droit de cité et je
vais vous dire aussi que les réactions
unanimes de solidarité de toute l'europe
démontre que ce n'est pas uniquement une
question de contentieux franco turque
mais d' attaque contre l'europe ses
valeurs son modèle de liberté
fondamentale et d'état de droit et je
voudrais rappeler qu'il y ait un rendez
vous monsieur le sénateur posées par le
conseil européen au mois d'octobre avant
même l'escaladent que j'ai constaté que
vous avez constaté le rendez vous c'est
si la turquie ne modifie pas
fondamentalement sa posture et
concrètement sa posture avant le conseil
européen de décembre
alors nous prendrons les mesures
nécessaires au niveau européen
l'encontre des autorités turques ou z
[Musique]